if you're in your head you're dead
what's that mean I guess there's kind of
a theme with these which is smart people
do really dumb things an example of that
is people who are in their head a lot
what I learned from this was a very
simple thing I want to be happy like
many people do but I did something that
most people don't do which is I try to
figure out how the hell do you actually
be happy one of the things about
actually being happy is that you need to
get out of your head most people who are
again the type people who listen to
podcast they are in their head they try
to think their way through life they
think their way through problems and
that serves them but then they think
they can think their way through feeling
that's not how emotion works I thought
if you think a certain thing you will
feel a certain way which will lead you
to do a certain thing if I think that
this person just cut me off while I was
driving I will feel pissed I will feel
angry and I will then do something in
retaliation I thought it's a one-way
Street then I realized like math
equations math equations are reversible
so the other way also works and it
actually works better in this case if
you do a thing you will feel differently
which will cause you to think
differently